dieser mann hat erfolg findet erfolg
aber nicht so wichtig er ist ein rund um
die welt gefragter referent doch sein
ego wieder klein halten
seine gagen sind hoch reichtum findet er
dennoch überflüssig und sie kennen seine
bücher ganz bestimmt es sind nämlich
fast alles bestseller zu gast heute bei
mir
rolf dobelli ich freue mich sehr
herzlich willkommen danke für die
einladung
ja herr der bälle sind sie ein leben das
selbst widerspruch
ich weiß nicht ich glaube nicht ja es
ist tatsächlich so ich habe erfolg
aber er hat sehr viel mit zufall zu tun
also ich würde mal sagen fast zu 100
prozent mit zufall zu tun und in dem
sinne hatte ich einfach glück und glück
ist kein grund stolz zu sein oder ein
großes ego aufzublasen
so ein glück ist einfach was es ist man
nimmt wenn es da ist und manchmal hat
man es nicht aber schön ist es doch oder
natürlich natürlich ich habe lieber
glück aus also unglück ich habe lieber
ein bestseller aus als keinen bestseller
natürlich dass es dinge die die schön
sind man nimmt sie mit aber man kann
nicht man kann sich nicht dran ketten
man kann nicht mal darauf hoffen dass es
passiert wenn sie passieren das sind
dinge die unsere außerhalb von unserer
kontrolle sind
und dann nimmt man sie eben an wenn sie
da sind und freut sich dass sie haben
trotzdem so was wahrscheinlich ihn
erfolgsrezept sie sind wahrscheinlich
einer der erfolgreichsten
kolumnenschreiber der schweiz und ihre
kolumnen werden dann eben immer ein
schöne bücher verpackt und schaffen es
auf die bestsellerliste
sie haben diese kondensierte form des
wissens auch gepflegt in ihrem
unternehmen geht abstrakt und ich habe
mich dazwischen gefragt ist eigentlich
diese idee der sage jetzt mal
lebensweisheit to go etwas was sie schon
lange fasziniert
es ist tatsächlich so habe ihn nur
rückblickend so dass ich dass mir das
auch auffällt als roten faden haben
das ist wiederum rückblickend gesehen
ich das unternehmen gesetzt habe ich mit
freunden gegründet und die idee hatte
ich schon damals gibt es so viele gute
bücher könnte man die nicht irgendwie
kürzer fassen zusammen fassen damit man
die kernpunkte verstanden hat und wenn
man es dann gut findet dann kann man
natürlich das buch lesen uns als ich
dann begonnen habe zu schreiben
besonders die sachbücher dann
ist das irgendwie in mir drin dieses
gehen des zusammenfassen das
komprimieren dass das auf den punkt
bringen sich drehen und ich könnte
irgendwie gar nicht daran dass bücher
scheinlich konnte kein sachbuch einfach
durch schreiben
es müssen dieses stück gesagt ist
übrigens auch viel einfacher zu
schweigen wenn man so ein stück schreibt
weil wenn sich durch schreiben müssen da
muss alles wirklich von a bis z
zusammenpasst und so hat man sowie
kleine so goose oder oder lego teilchen
die man zusammen stellen kann und am
schluss kann man sie nach der
reihenfolge nach arrangieren ich denke
es ist auch für den schriftsteller
einfacher so zu schreiben ist in diesem
zusammenhang natürlich ich ja berlin
eingefahrener dieses unterbruch
wunderbare buch geschrieben hatte war
tolstoi igel und fuchs und da beschreibt
eigentlich zwei typen von menschen
nämlich die einen sind füchse die wissen
ganz viele unterschiedliche dinge und
interessieren sich auch für vieles und
es gibt die igel die haben eine große
idee im kopf die sie verfolgen
sie sind ein fuchs oder ja ich bin ich
bin eher ein fuchs ich habe freude an
ideen ich das ist mein fehler ich bin
verliebt in ideen und viele ideen und
das kann aus der wissenschaft sein das
ganze philosophie sein
das kann aus dem leben sein das sind
ideen die ich sammle suche zu verknüpfen
zu verarbeiten und ich bin nicht der
mann der in die tiefe geht und dann
wirklich eine idee bis ins letzte
ausdrückt hat das auch etwas damit zu
tun dass sie auch gar nicht an die eine
idee glauben das ist natürlich auch ein
faktor es gibt nicht die eine idee die
gibt es nicht also das hat mich dann
beschäftigt bei dieser frage was macht
ein gutes leben aus und als ich auf
diese frage gekommen bin ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen durchs leben zu gehen
ohne diese frage jemals ernsthaft zu
stellen zu beantworten habe ich
festgestellt nein es gibt nicht diese
eine große idee die einen glücklich
macht sich ein gutes leben bringt es
gibt nicht den knopf drücken mussten
dann kommt aus und diesen heiligen grau
gibt es nicht sondern es ist wie in den
wissenschaften wie beispielsweise in der
medizin wie in der ökonomie wenn man ein
problem zu lösen hat dann gibt es viele
dinge die man darum herum lösen muss
respektive viele schrauben die man reden
muss damit es gut kommt und so ist es
eben auch beim leben es gibt nicht den
einen knopf sondern es gibt viele viele
kleine dinge die man berücksichtigt
sie haben jetzt gerade das stichwort
schon gegeben ihr buch zum glück sie
haben ja tatsächlich wenn wir kurz
zurück schauen eigentlich zuerst primär
geschrieben über fehler also 52
denkfehler dann 52 irrwege und jetzt
sind die 52 überraschenden wege zum
glück rausgekommen die kunst des guten
lebens und da sagen sie auch eigentlich
ist das sowas wie eine toolbox und sie
vergleichen das mit dem schweizer
taschenmesser das müssen sie erklären
genau also ein schweizer taschenmesser
hat hat jetzt ich weiß nicht das hat
vermutlich zehn verschiedene tools also
zehn verschiedene instrumente zehn
verschiedene werkzeuge dran und ein
schweizer sagt schwester sophie
taschenmesser auf hochdeutsch mit dem
kann man nicht jedes problem lösen und
mit meiner toolbox kann man auch nicht
jedes problem lösen aber gleichzeitig
braucht man nicht immer alle werkzeuge
an einem taschenmesser um bei einer
situation meistern fragt man eins oder
zwei
und das ist dasselbe bein kapitel meines
buches
und weil es 52 kapitel sind vergleiche
das geld mit einem taschenmesser mit 52
sorgen werkzeugen dran
man kann nicht alles lösen damit aber
man braucht auch nicht immer aus dem
kopf zu haben alle diese 52 werkzeuge
es reicht wenn man je nach situation
zwei oder drei anwendet um die situation
zu lösen indem man steckt zum beispiel
hat man toxische gefühle oder man
interpretiert die welt pause oder sich
selbst aus und dann kommen zwei oder
drei solche werkzeuge zum einsatz
auch wieder den stichworten toxische
gefühle da muss man natürlich darüber
sprechen
und tatsächlich wollte ich mit ihnen
über so ein paar tools sprechen und mit
zu einem toxischen gefühl anfang mit
ihnen nämlich mit dem leid sie sagen
nein ist das giftigste aller gefühle
verabschieden sie sich davon ja so nah
dies überhaupt dass ich denke mal dass
das vorherrschende gefühl in unserer
modernen gesellschaft wir vergleichen
uns ständig mit anderen menschen
wir vergleichen uns im job bei und ja
ist er jetzt hat die promotion bekommen
ist er aufgestiegen oder nicht hatte
eine lohnerhöhung gekriegt oder nicht
darf der auf diese geschäftsreise oder
an jene konferenz reisen irgendwo in der
karibik oder nicht wir vergleichen uns
ständig mit anderen menschen und mit den
sozialen medien ist das noch viel
stärker geworden
vergleichen wir uns mit unserem hund
oder 200-300 virtuellen freunden und
denken dann natürlich die hätten ein
besseres leben weil der content die die
an den hochstellen ist natürlich super
kuratiert aber trotzdem wir sind ständig
in diesem vergleichs modus und dieser
vergleich ist quasi der generator für
einheit und neid ist ein toxisches ist
ein giftiges gefühl weil ohne neid geht
es auch um man lebt viel bessere leiden
hier gibt es ein paar ansätze wie man
die zeit einigermaßen in den griff
bekommt 23 gedankliche tools gedankliche
werkzeuge
niemand ist neid in den griff bekommt
und glauben sie mir das leben ist viel
schöner überlegt wir müssen möchte ich
gleich noch sprechen hat da wir noch
kurz bei dieser bei diesem toxischen
gefühl sie haben jetzt gesagt das leben
ist viel besser ohne einheit und könnte
natürlich auch fragen na ja eine
gesellschaft vielleicht nicht unbedingt
zumindest war bernard dem mond will ein
philosoph und und sozial theoretiker des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts terror ja der
meinung in der sogenannten bienen farbe
dass der wohlstand eigentlich in einer
lasterhaften gesellschaft besonders zum
erblühen käme und zwar unter anderem
weil die leute zum beispiel neidisch
sind und der neidische seitenblick
treibt sie zu höchstleistungen an
das hat doch was für sich oder es so
kann man argumentieren allerdings sieht
man dann nur jeweils die erfolgreichen
also wenn es alle neidisch sind dann
gibt es ein paar die dann erfolg haben
durch diesen neid stellte angetrieben
und da gibt es gleich weil ich solche
die dann trotz diesem leiden irgendwo
hinkommen und man nimmt dann jene die
werden dann eingeladenen teams aus dem
talk show sind die medien die kommen
dann auf die auf die titelblätter der
zeitung die wir nie vorgehabt haben
wegen dem man sich gar nicht alle
anderen die auch durch diesen neid
angestachelt worden die nicht erfolg
haben
also nein ist was für die erfolgreichen
die dürfen ja nicht lösen dann auch
nachher sagen sie seien wegen dem wegen
des neides seien die erfolgreich gewesen
erfolg hat wie gesagt eine eine
komponente des zuschauers die unheimlich
hoch ist und deshalb glaube ich nicht
dass neid 1 1
ein wirkliche treiber ist von
wirtschaftlichem erfolg es sind es sind
vermutlich andere dinge die die
wirtschaftlich antreiben
aber neid ist es sicher nicht ich würde
sogar sagen sie haben wenn sie keine
zeit haben haben sie genauso ein drive
irgendetwas zu erreichen etwas zu
erzählen
aber sie es ist ein schönes der weg
dorthin der weg zum ziel ist ein schöner
aus wenn sich durch night machen
eine interessante frage wäre ja auch
noch sie haben dass sie zu einem
beschrieben sagt kamlage leben in einer
sehr in einer leitkultur fast schon das
hat was du tun dies mit diesen ständigen
wettbewerb wir sprechen ja auch von
einer rating gesellschaft wir machen war
top oder flop
man könnte ja auch sagen wenn ich das
jetzt mal so ein bisschen wie gegen sie
bürste sozusagen
na ja früher hatten wir vielleicht den
eindruck unsere positionen der
gesellschaft ist uns vorgegeben vom
schicksal oder von gott wir sind hat das
grafe geboren mein gott ja damit der
neidische blick auch nichts
heute kann man auch sagen naja neid
zeigt auch unter umständen dass sie auch
die möglichkeit haben besser zu werden
und uns aus unserer position zu befreien
ja natürlich das zeigte neid natürlich
können wir besser werden wir können uns
wirklich anstrengen durch neue und etwas
erschaffen wie gesagt man kann sich auch
anstrengen ohne ohne ohne neid aber wenn
sie neid haben es angenommen sie haben
einen gewissen vornehmen wird es machen
monetären sie haben jetzt ein einkommen
von falls nicht 300.000 einer halben
million erreicht dann beginnen sie sich
zu vergleich mit den anderen die auch
eine halbe million verdienen und zwar
vergleichen sie sich dann nach oben
tendenziell auch der andere hat eine
million und ich möchte auch keine
million dann haben sie auch eine million
später fünf jahre später damit beginnen
sich zu vergleichen mit denen die 1 5
millionen haben oder zehn millionen
haben und der neid macht die ganze
glückseligkeit die sich durch diese
durch den wirtschaftlichen erfolg
aufgebaut haben zunichte der neid macht
wirklich diese glückseligkeit dieses
gefühl von glück zunichte und deshalb
müssen wir diese toxische emotionen in
den griff bekommen
ich sage ihnen jetzt selina eine kurze
geschichte ich habe einen freund der ist
3 wawrinka der privatbankier in der
schweiz
der hat einen kunden von ihm besucht auf
einer einsamen insel ebene und
griechischen mehr wunderschöne
privatinsel er hat eine eine villa dort
oben hat zwei töchter aus wunderbaren
gute ehe aus super und der mein freund
kaum zu ihm
zu diesen kunden und er war in tränen
der war total unmöglich
und dann hat ihn gefragt warum sind sie
den sohn glücklich und er hat gesagt vor
15 minuten ist der bill gates mit seiner
ist super 8 form einer insel durch
gefahren und da habe ich realisiert dass
ich das nie erreichen werde
also der mann hat vermutlich etwa 300
400 millionen auf dem konto
aber das reicht eben nicht wie die
superyacht von bill gates und das hat
ihn zerstört wie idiotisch muss sein
hirn ticken um so reagieren zu können
und das ist neid macht mehr kaputt als
es alles als positive auswirkungen hat
scheint uns ein jetzt ein zweites tool
an oder ein zweiter hinweisen ihres
buches sie haben auch das gute leben hat
zu tun mit der konstruktiven er
interpretation von tatsachen gibt es da
ein gutes beispiel
ja parkkosten parks strafzettel
ich habe mich fliegen aufgeregt ein
strafzettel
also ich habe ein büro in der altstadt
von deren da kann man kaum parken habe
auf geparkt schnell etwas holen im büro
das schneller eben das arbeiten wieder
runter ins auto und schon hat man ein
paar an strafzeiten und das hat mich
früher aufgeregt diese 40 franken
strafzeit wegen zehn minuten falsch
parken und eine frau die ich haben jetzt
eine regel und wir haben immer am anfang
des jahres sagen wir uns ergeben einem
bestimmten betrag am ende des jahres für
gute zwecke aus dieser betrag ist fix -
alles drauf zettel
also wenn wir jetzt einen strafzettel
von 40 franken bekommen dann ziehen wir
das einfach am ende des jahres ab der
bank
diese stiftung ein bisschen wenig 40
franken weniger die 40 franken gehen an
den start ist auch ein guter zweck und
alle sind glücklich und ich habe keinen
stress mehr
das ist eine neue müssen sie genauso ist
neu und eigentlich ist es ein verfehlen
der buße sie deuten das um mich mal zb
michael sandel würde das so sagen in
seinem buch was man für geld nicht
kaufen kann sie sie deuten die busse um
in eine gebühr natürlich und das mache
ich für die eigene beruhigung und die
eigene beruhigung also diese
seelenfrieden das ist so mein ziel des
lebens das ist eine große komponente des
guten lebens ist diese seele frieden zu
haben egal was von außen angeschossen
wird es kommen schlechte nachrichten
werden krankheiten kommen es gibt weiß
nicht börsencrashs was auch immer aber
dass man diesen seelenfrieden behält und
das ist eines dieser kleine tools
mentale buchhaltung nimmt man den in der
wissenschaft ist eine klein ein kleines
tool ein kleines werkzeug wie man diesen
in den frieden behält trotz dieser
parkbusse jetzt darf man das natürlich
nicht übertreiben man kann sich jetzt
nicht man darf es sich nicht diese
freiheit jetzt einfach auf kaufen und
sagen ich brauche jetzt überall
das passiert bei uns etwa zwei- oder
dreimal im jahr einfach stressvermeidung
ein anderes mal schauen wie es nach
dieser sendung ist ein anderes tut
früher habe ich mich etwas aufgeregt am
preis steigern und kaffee hat früher 350
gekostet da kommt das nächste mal ins
restaurant oder kostet 550 fast kaum
noch nicht sein so eine massive
prozentuale preissteigerung das ist auch
eine frechheit und ich habe mich dann
aufgelegt gehabt emotion generiert für
nichts und wieder nichts
und heute habe ich mir einen betrag
festgelegt unter dem ich mich nicht mehr
aufregen das sind in meinem fall 10
franken
egal was es ist was unter 10 franken ist
da lege ich mich nicht auf ob ein café
einen franken kostet unter 9 franken auf
1 43 franken kostet 159 das ist mir
völlig egal
unter 10 franken dass die limite wo ich
mich nicht mehr aufregen ich konsumiere
nicht mehr das mehr oder weniger ich
gebe nicht mehr oder weniger geld aus
aber ich spare mir die ganzen negativen
emotionen das ist auch eine art dieser
mentalen buchhaltung also auch eines
auch ein solches tool also das werkzeug
für den inneren frieden
dieses umdeuten das finden wir ja ganz
vielen kontexten wie viel eine postkarte
an die mir jemand mal geschenkt hat da
stand drauf ich bin nicht klein ich bin
ein konzentrat passt passt zu mir habe
ich mir da näher an die wand gehängt
aber ich habe jetzt
gefragt kann man wirklich alles so
zurechtbiegen und umdeuten es gibt da
diese bücher ich habe mich über diese
titel immer furchtbar aufgeregt von
ruediger dahlke krankheit ausweg
schicksal als chance da denkt man doch
na ja es kommt noch der moment wo dann
einfach fertig ist mit umdeuten wo man
auch anerkennen muss gewisse dinge sind
einfach schlimm und wir müssen jetzt
nicht einfach zu recht vernünftigen und
versuchen das irgendwie einzupassen ein
rationales gefühl das stimmt tatsächlich
also wenn sie wenn sie krank sind sie
haben krebs
dann gibt es nichts dran zu rütteln dann
haben sie krebs aber sie können daran
verzweifeln oder sie können sagen was
ist diese krebs kann ich irgendwas tun
dagegen ich versuche das maximal
maximale zu tun was in einem rahmen der
beeinflussung liegt und da gibt es viele
dinge die ich nicht tun kann das muss
ich einfach annehmen und dieses annehmen
das ist auch so eine art das ist auch
eine art werkzeug dass man dinge annimmt
und akzeptiert die man nicht verändern
kann
es gibt nichts idiotisches als sich
aufzuregen über dinge die man nicht
verändern kann und dieses annehmen dass
es hat mit mit übung zu tun uns hat
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit reife
zu tun es hat auch damit zu tun dass man
sich jeweils überlegt was könnte alles
schlimmes passieren in meinem leben
das ist ein gedanke der viele leute
nicht gern tun ich mache das sehr gern
weil es hilfen wir dann vorauszuschauen
es kann alles passieren gibt es gewisse
dinge die ich schon jetzt abtreten kann
und dass andere bin ich dann bereits zu
tragen
ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht sagen
angenommen ein kind von mir würde ich
sterben
ich könnte das sicher nicht so locker
wegstecken aber wenn ich mir überlege
bewusst jeden tag dass das passieren
kann dass dieses kind eigentlich nicht
mein kind ist anders ist geschenkt vom
universum um jetzt 1 1 ein zitat von
epic dazu brauchen dann glaube ich ist
man ein bisschen nicht viel aber ein
bisschen stärker fordern und sie jetzt
eigentlich eine historische übung der
historischen philosophie die sogenannte
prä meditation album das man sich eben
überlegt was alles schlimmes passieren
kann die kommen später noch ausführlich
auf die store zu sprechen
ich würde gerne noch einmal kurz bei
diesen verschiedenen beispielen bleiben
eigentlich scheint es doch sowas zu sein
auch wenn zweckpessimismus
also mach dir bloß keine falschen
erwartungen dann wirst du auch nicht
enttäuscht
wie geht das zusammen mit vielleicht
auch gewissen ideen des positiven
denkens was ja auch so verbreitet ist
heutzutage denkt positiv denkt positiv
das funktioniert eben nicht weil es kann
ab und zu funktionieren wenn man glück
hat aber eingesprungen sind jetzt nicht
weil die dinge entwickeln sich ja nicht
so wie man sie sich erhofft
normalerweise die welt kann man ja nicht
nach seinem eigenen geschmack bauen
sondern die welt wir sind in eine welt
geboren dies alles andere als einfach
das leben ist kompliziert es ist
schwierig selbst für leute die
privilegiert sind wie ich mir geht's gut
ich habe sehr viel glück aber das leben
ist anstrengend und da kommen gewisse
dinge auf einen zu die man nicht mag und
ich denke es ist man lebt besser damit
wenn man sagt das sind all diese
schlechten dinge die auf einen zu
treffen können und man ist dann
gewappnet um die anzunehmen und zwar
nicht nur sachlich annehmen sondern auch
emotional anzunehmen als wenn sie sagen
ja es kommt alles gut ich muss nur
positiv denken ich muss nur meine meine
guten gedanken ist universum schicken
dann jetzt mehr gegeben ich muss nun
überlegen ich will eine million haben
auf dem konto und fünf jahre später habe
ich dann eine million auf dem konto
funktioniert hat nicht das geht leider
nicht aber es ist sie leben besser wenn
sie diese per meditation verlor um
wirklich dieses dieses negative denken
in sich einbauen und und dann vielleicht
kommt so und in vielen fällen kommt das
besser und ansätze glücklich sie sagen
ja auch das ist eigentlich eine negative
kunst des lebens gibt und das ist in
diesem buch drin genau ist das dass der
westliche moment das ist ein
wesentlicher moment zu überlegen was
kann als positives was kann auch als
negatives passieren und dann das
auszuschließen versuchen möglichst
auszuschließen
da laufen sie besser aus wenn sie
versuchen aus positive obendrauf zu
zerstückeln also es gibt sowie
zweifelsohne zwei lebensphilosophien so
könnte man es auch anschauen
es gibt jene bücher die sagen du musst
das noch machen und das und das machen
und dann kommt es gut und ich sage du
musst alles negative entfernen und dann
kommt es gut und ich denke beim
negativen ist man besser beraten weil
das
dies sind dinge die handfeste sind man
kann mit dem finger drauf zeigen was
alles negativ passieren kann dann dass
wenn es wenn es möglich ist wegnehmen
also wenn es ja was auch jetzt hatte ich
noch da und ich sagte diese app
herunterladen und ich sollte doch 30
minuten joggen gehen und ich sollte noch
45 minuten meditieren jeden tagen und
und aufeinander aufbauen also ich finde
ich bin ein verfechter von reduzieren
vom wegnehmen sie offenbaren sich in
diesem buch ja auch was sie bringen
beispiele ihres eigenen lebens eben zb
die parkbuchten finden sich auch hier
drin
ich habe jetzt wieder zwischen auch
gefragt gibt es eigentlich so den
wirklichen test für sie ja so gab es
schon fälle in ihrem leben wo sie sagten
da war ich jetzt wirklich
herausgefordert da muss ich jetzt echt
sagen habe ich mir meinen werkzeugkasten
meine toolbox angeguckt bewusst einen
selber nicht mehr weiter nein aber es
gibt ist ganz grosse fälle sowie tod in
der familie
das gab es nichts zum glück noch nicht
aber es wird mal kommen meine eltern
werden muss sterben
dass das ist ein foul und ich werde auf
aussterben oder krank werden das ist
auch gegeben dass das kommt noch
aber ich sehe es immer wieder und
kleinen beispielen wo ich nicht so weit
bin ich sein möchte gerade gestern und
so kindel
die waren zu spät ich habe es wenige
jahre genau zwei jungs diesem vier jahre
alten zwillinge sind sicher näher als
aus den eltern das heißt man kann die
fast nicht führen die sind eigentlich
man kriegt es gar nicht richtig kennt
hier schwierig für sie managen er gern
ecke und dann holten die mich vorwärts
machen und dann habe ich die nerven
verloren hat geschrieben habe jetzt
kommen wir wieder zu spät wege neu weil
ich sonst machen könnt ihr euch nicht
ganz so weit habe ich mich doch
historiker sein
das ist genau das was ich nicht will das
heißt ich musste an mir arbeiten dann
tatsächlich das fließt dann jeweils ein
in die abend betrachtung ich habe vor
dem schlafengehen mache ich so eine
betrachtung was lief alles schlecht an
diesem tag wo könnte ich mich im sinne
des des todes 1 verbessern und das
postamt tatsächlich an die versuche das
jetzt zu unterdrücken und und und und
nicht mehr auszuflippen aber ich bin ein
mensch und ab und zu friedrich rastete
aus und das ist noch kein weise schauen
wir uns noch ein drittes rezept kann sie
sagen auch man soll sich nicht als
ausnahmeerscheinung
und im gegenteil eben nicht ich bin das
großartige chemie sondern sich einfach
eine nische suchen wenn ich sie zitieren
darf sie sagen eine eigene nische suchen
oder sein eigenes rennen lancieren um
dann darin zum sieg zu fahren
ja findet man denn seine eigene mission
bell nicht durch nachdenken und gerne
höhle gehen und zu überlegen was gefällt
mir das könnte ich gern machen also die
die eigene berufung zu finden dass da
werde ich häufig gefragt hat ob ich
finde ich denn meine berufung und ich
sage immer berufung das ist ein
christliches konstrukt also man wird
berufen von gott und dann wird man nicht
oder gegen was aber in der heutigen zeit
berufung das gibt's nicht
sie sind nicht berufen ein besten
überhaupt überhaupt obst ob ein buch ein
bestseller wird oder nicht ob ein buch
sich 10.000 mal unter zehn millionen mal
verkauft ist komplett außer haben eine
kontrolle
ich versuche einfach das beste buch zu
schreiben nach meinen möglichkeiten noch
meinen beschränkten möglichkeiten
ich hätte man gern ich könnte
festzuschreiben
aber nach meinen möglichkeiten versuchen
das beste zu machen und dann geht das
buch raus und dann kommt vielleicht auf
die beste ließ sodass kommt nicht das
liegt außerhalb meiner kontrolle und
viele leute sagen ich muss sie mich
reingehen meditieren dann finde ich
meinen ist dann finde ich quasi meine
berufung
und ich glaube so geht das nicht ich
glaube sie müssen schauen was haben sie
von track record also was haben sie in
der vergangenheit gemacht dass
überdurchschnittlich gut war
also wo sind sie überdurchschnittlich
stark in welchen fähigkeiten und nicht
nur was sie glauben sondern wo haben
sich devisen das überdurchschnittlich
gut sind und dann dort bleiben in diesem
circle of competence in diesem
kompetenzkreis bleiben und den und den
möglichst vertiefen
ich denke das ist dann das eigene rennen
dass man fährt und dann ist man auch
unabhängig von von der konkurrenz sie
haben ja auch eine lange romane
geschrieben damit waren sie nicht so
erfolgreich wie mit diesen dingen hier
war das für sie so was wie in nischen
sucht fehler
das habe ich so aus
ich weiß auch nicht warum ich begonnen
haben ist wahrscheinlich habe ich habe
es versucht aber es ist tatsächlich so
dass es andere leute gibt die viel
besser romane schreiben können als ich
und das ist definitiv nicht in meinem
kompetenzkreis wenn ich denke die sind
wie man kompetenzkreis die sind ihm eine
nische drin
bei den romanen
das ist ziemlich außerhalb es ist
wunderschön ist die steuerlisten an
dänische hat natürlich macht man muss
man suchen und man muss und man muss man
muss möglichst in den jungen jahren
viele stichproben machen ins leben
hinein das mit damit man sieht wo bin
ich überdurchschnittlich gut das trifft
man sich hier nicht beim ersten mal tief
man vermutlich nicht bei den nächsten
drei jahren sondern muss viele
stichproben auf und plötzlich merkt man
es da zieht da bin ich über den scheitel
und dann am besten dabei bleiben jetzt
gewisse dinge sind ja aber doch so dass
man sich bemühen muss und nicht nur
jetzt aber überdurchschnittlich gut
seien von vornherein sondern sich auch
wissen aneignen muss sich da richtig
reinknien und gerade weil sie ein mensch
sind der viel wissen kondensiert das ja
auch eben mit geld abstrakt compressed
knowledge war damals das stichwort
gemacht haben mit diesen
zusammenfassungen von wichtigen büchern
die man sich herunterladen kann hat mich
dann sehr erstaunt dass sie zur bildung
eigentlich sie relativ negativ äußern
sie sagen da nämlich in diesem buch
hören sie auf alles mögliche wissen
anzuhäufen der absicht ihre
berufsaussichten zu verbessern
ökonomisch liegt darin keine power mehr
gelungen ist heute nur noch als hobby
sinnvoll für den beruf also dieser satz
fällt die berufsaussichten zu steigen
ist allgemeinbildung heute nicht mehr
wichtig heute ist viel wichtiger dass
sie in ihrer nische wieder in ihrem
kompetenzkreis möglichst gut sind aber
wird man gut und -bindung man indem man
möglichst viele stunden investiert in
diese fähigkeit also wenn sie sie werden
zu einem meister ihres fachs sei das
jetzt irgendwas sei dass die
schriftstellerei sein das modellieren
was sie tun sei das sei das ein fall für
einen friseur wenn sie viele hundert
wenn nicht tausende von stunden
investieren
genau zu erinnern wir uns natürlich über
lehrer gehen dh sie haben vielleicht
lehrer gehabt sie haben vorbilder wo sie
dinge abgucken können wir haben viel
gemacht sie haben positive vorbilder
sich habe negative vorbilder und können
sich anhand von diesen positiven und
negativen vorbildern ihren weg
erschaffen aber fördert das nicht die
fachidioten letztlich
ja aber sie können heute nur noch als
fachidiot überleben
demnächst arbeitslos
also jetzt wenn sie jetzt nicht den job
sie sind ja sie schreiben auch noch
bücher aber auch moderatorin sind sie
müssen sie möglichst gut sein als
moderatorin und nicht noch tausend
andere dinge können heute wenn sie sach
idiot sind und zwar am besten weltweit
führend dann haben sie es erreicht
ökonomisch ob sie eine freude haben um
noch das andere in der freizeit das
andere wissen in der freizeit noch rein
sauren das ist natürlich ihnen
überlassen
das ist ja irgendwie auch interessant
also ich verstehe was sie sahen und
gleichzeitig denke ich bei mir zum
beispiel und ich glaube das kommt in
diesem buch schon auch vor man geht es
doch auch darum dinge zu tun einfach um
der sache willen bildung geben um freude
daran so natürlich und nicht auch nicht
im büro beruf so zu ergreifen dass man
denkt da ist meine nische da kann ich
eben besonders erfolgreich sein sondern
manchmal auch sinnlos in die welt
hinausgehen und einfach etwas anpacken
gebe ich ihnen absolut recht aber mein
satz den sie jetzt gerade vorgelesen
haben heißt für die berufsaussichten
respektive für ihren beruflichen weg ist
es besser wenn sie in die tiefe gehen
natürlich in der freizeit um himmels
willen
lesen sie möglichst viele bücher von
möglichst über möglichst viele themen
weil das ist schön wunderbar jetzt gehen
wir zur richtigen bildung aber jetzt
möchte ich wirklich mit ihnen über die
store sprechen weil das ja wirklich ein
wichtiges thema ist bei ihnen das haben
sie auch am anfang ihres buches sie
haben verschiedene quellen sie befassen
sich mit verschiedenen formen der
psychologie der modernen psychologie
verhaltensökonomie spielt eine große
rolle auch investmentbanking da werden
wir auch noch darüber sprechen aber auch
die philosophische schule
der store also diese denkrichtung die
ungefähr 300 vor christus angefangen hat
bis ungefähr 200 nach christus gedauert
hat also eine lange epoche und in dieser
antiken philosophie ist eigentlich eine
ganz ganz wichtigen momente ist diese
idee der effekt kontrolle und um ein
bisschen herauszufinden wie man diesen
effekt kontrollen nicht einordnen muss
habe ich christoph helbig getroffen ist
professor für philosophie an der
universität
rich und er hat uns dazu auch etwas
zusammen ja die stahl vertritt da
eigentlich eine radikale position wie
radikal die eigentlich ist versteht man
denke ich am besten wenn man sie
abgrenzt von der position die
aristoteles vertreten hat aristoteles
hat die idee vertreten also kein starker
aristoteles hat die idee vertreten das
das ziel sein muss die affekte zu
mäßigen
die sogenannte mit rio partie ich denke
wissen alle
wenn wir so etwas wie zaren oder
eifersucht oder neid empfinden dann
gerät er schnell außer kontrolle und der
anspruch aus ästhetischer sicht muss
sein solche effekte vernünftig zu
gestalten sie zu kultivieren
gleichzeitig vertritt aristoteles aber
die these dass effekte sogar im bereich
der moral zwingenden notwendig sind wenn
sie zeige von schreiendem unrecht werden
und es dabei belassen würde aristoteles
sagen haben sie sogar moralisch falsch
gemacht
sie sollen sich empören und an der
stelle sind die sträucher viel radikaler
die sträucher würden eben sagen es kommt
nicht darauf an die effekte zu mäßigen
sondern der anspruch muss sein sie ganz
loszuwerden und das ideal ist die
apathie die freiheit von den effekten
und da ist natürlich wirklich eine sehr
radikale idee also wenn sie
beispielsweise an so etwas denken wie
mitleid
dann hält die steuer das spricht für ein
laster ja jemand leidet und die leute
einfach auch er hat das davon
das ist in einer bestimmten sich
durchaus vernünftig aber man empfindet
doch einen gewissen schau da die
befreiung von den effekten halte ich
erstens für nicht erreichbar und
zweitens auch für kein sinnvolles ideal
ich denke es gehört zur verwundbarkeit
des menschen dazu sich einzugestehen
dass beispielsweise schlimme dinge
passieren und darauf angemessen
auch effektiv zu reagieren insofern wäre
ich da aristotelische und würde auf die
kultivierung der effekte setzen aber
nicht auf die effekt losigkeit effekt
losigkeit apathie ist dass ich möchte
leben ohne negative effekte negative
gefühle
aber das ist natürlich schon richtig wie
bringt man nicht weg man kann sie
reduzieren aber ganz weg bringt man sie
nicht historiker bringt die ganz weg
weil diesen tief verwurzelt denn wenn
ich ein schreiendes kind sehe oder wenn
ich ein wirkliches unglück sieht und
dann empört mich das auch jetzt ist es
schlau solche effekte zu haben wenn wir
medien konsumieren und die ganze zeit
nur diese negativen nachrichten sehen
und hören dann habe mich ständig effekte
und es macht das macht uns
handlungsunfähig und hier ist eben eine
stoische haltung oder ein möglichst
torische haltung vernünftige zu sagen wo
sind die wirklichen probleme wo wir nur
wo wir nur ein theater gemacht wo sind
die wirklichen probleme und dann dort
eingreifen
es ist ja so dass ein mensch viel
stärker betroffen ist wenn etwas
schlimmes jetzt da passiert vor einem
als 10.000 kilometern an einem anderen
ort wo es noch viel mehr unrecht gibt wo
es wäre rational dort einzugreifen oder
das unrecht größere ist oder das leiden
größer ist aber nach aristoteles wird
man dahin getrieben seien zu dazu helfen
wo es gerade jetzt ist und das andere
liegen zu lassen dass andere größere
denn leid liegen zu lassen
sie greifen jetzt so auch eine
populärwissenschaftliche kritik das
mitleid der empathie auf indem sie sagen
das macht eigentlich so auch etwas wie
uns ihre leiten wo eigentlich die
wichtigen themen sind aber die position
war ja noch radikaler und ein stück weit
vertreten die die ja auch dass sie sagen
mitleid ist eigentlich unsinn
und das ist wirklich die position auch
der story her habe ich das heraus
gestrichen hat und ich habe auch hier
wieder einen satz gefunden über den ich
mit ihnen gerne diskutieren würde
sie haben natürlich recht ich reiße das
immer so aus dem zusammenhang so macht
man darf sie können sich dann
verteidigen
es gibt keinen grund sich schuldig zu
fühlen wenn es ihnen zufällig besser
geht aus einem bomber opfer in aleppo
es könnte genauso gut umgekehrt sein
über diesen satz bin ich gestolpert weil
im moment ich konsumiere in jungs im
gegensatz zu ihnen sie möchten das ja
lieber nicht tun
ich meine man diese bilder sieht dann
denkt man doch natürlich muss ich da
emotionen haben wir natürlich soll ich
mir das antun
ich weiß nicht wo man sich das angucken
muss oder ob man sich einfach bewusst
werden sowie was für probleme es gibt
und wie viel leid an anderen orten
entsteht ich denke dass emotionalisieren
oder dass sich mitreißen lassen von
diesen bildern hilft nicht wirklich
diese probleme zu lösen
ich denke im gegensatz dazu wenn man
abstand hat und das ganze eben möglichst
ohne effekte möglichst ohne gefühle
anschaut löst man das problem
ich weiß es klingt unmenschlich und es
klingt hart und es klingt ich lassen wir
lassen jedoch die moralische bewertung
nach außen vor mich interessiert an
zuallererst mal noch diese frage was
macht eigentlich information mit uns
weil sie pochen ja so darauf dass sie
haben das bringt uns eigentlich erstmal
gar nichts aber nehme ich eine andere
debatte fleisch essen zum beispiel viele
leute gegen noch sagen mal in einen
schlachthof gegangen zu sein oder sich
darüber informiert zu haben was
eigentlich in einem komplett oder in
einer wurst da drin ist und wie dieses
tier gehalten wurde
das macht etwas mit mir und viel
aktivismus entsteht doch auch aus
information oder würden sie das
bestreite ja da haben sie recht
vieles kann man über bilder und die
besucher erlebnisse herausnehmen man
kann das lernen auf der anderen seite es
ist halt so
diese effekte verleiten uns häufig zu
falschen schlüssen und deshalb finde ich
es besser man hat diese effekte
einigermaßen unter kontrolle man empört
sich nicht ständig über diese bilder und
schaut das ganze aus einer gewissen
rationalen distanz an
ich sage nicht man soll gar nichts tun
im gegenteil wie leben wir haben ein
besseres leben wenn es der umwelt auch
besser geht
das war schon eine stoische sicht also
die die gemeinschaft ist wichtig es geht
einem best sondern auch gut geht und man
soll da energie investieren aber
trotzdem es braucht eine gewisse
eigentlich sind abstand zu diesen
gefühlen also das heißt konkret der
grund warum ich anderen unter umständen
helfen sollte ist dass es mir nachher
auch besser geht und gar nicht dass es
diesen menschen schlecht geht
nein so würde ich es nicht sagen so ist
es auch investoren nicht gemeint die
store hat vier kardinaltugenden eine
davon mit gerechtigkeit und die
gerechtigkeit heißt gerechtigkeit
bedeutet es soll genannten auch google
nicht dass es mir noch besser geht
sondern grundsätzlich soll ist den
menschen an gut gehen sie sorgen
möglichst wenig leid haben sie sagen ein
gutes leben sagt nicht ein euphorisches
glückliches leben
aber sie sagen die möglichkeit haben ein
gutes leben zu leben jetzt wenn ihr
einmal zurückkomme zu dieser geschichte
mit den news wenn ich sie beim wort
nehmen was wäre denn die korrekte
haltung was ich meine wenn wir das jetzt
umdrehen und sagen okay dann konsumiere
ich jetzt überhaupt keine news mehr und
man kann ja auch hintergrundgeschichten
lesen das geht ja in den sogenannten
used in den medien jetzt nicht nur um
die steirischen bilder sondern es geht
auch um die zusammenhänge die
dargestellt werden wenn ich das nicht
tue dann erfahre ich gar nichts aber
dann komme ich ja auch nicht ins handeln
deswegen es gibt zwei es gibt eigentlich
drei gute wege wie sie trotzdem die welt
verstehen können das eine sind lange
artikel also nicht die kleinen ganz
kurzen snippets 20 minuten oder so
sondern lange artikel hintergrundartikel
fünfseitige zehnseitige artikel dann bei
goldene weg sind bücher und das mussten
sie müssen nicht aktuelle bücher seien
also wenn sie jetzt ein buch über syrien
lesen dann ist das buch vermutlich vor
einem jahr geschrieben worden und die
irische schiff vor zwei jahren gemacht
worden
aber trotzdem es gibt ihnen trotzdem ein
gutes bild wie diese welt funktioniert
was hat dazu geführt und zu können sich
dann überlegen was könnte noch daraus
entstehen aber in einem buch haben sie
all diese zusammenhänge und der dritte
schöne weg ist ein bisschen elitär wie
ich sie reden mit menschen die wirklich
etwas in diesem konflikt verstehen also
sie lesen sie reden mit mit leuten wie
in syrien gewesen sind sie reden mit
fröschen die auf diesem gebiet arbeiten
und mit korrespondenten dort gewesen
sind also sie haben den direkten kontakt
mit diesen menschen
das können natürlich nicht alle tun aber
das ist auch nicht aus derzeit probleme
ist die zeit für reden aber das ist so
der dritte weg bücher das sind
ultralange artikel oder dann wirklich
sprechen mit menschen die wirklich etwas
gestehen sie schreiben sich für
katastrophen zu interessieren das sei
reiner war lloris muss ja wenn man so
sagt ja ich muss doch wissen was geht
ich muss doch wissen wie viel diese
bombe wie viele menschen sind jetzt bei
einem attentat ums leben gekommen man
muss nicht alles wissen
dieses passt ihn vermutlich schlimm ist
auch auf anderen planeten in anderen
sonnensystemen gibt es gibt sicher auch
leben da passieren schlimme dinge und
dieser herr der bälle sie glauben da
gibt's zum mars menschen oder nicht
marsmenschen aber es gibt wissen dass
sehen einzelne haar ihm ein stein ist
unsere galaxie unsere galaxie besteht
aus 100 milliarden von sonnensystem
gewesen dass im durchschnitt jede sonne
einen 23 planeten hat und es gibt 100
milliarden galaxien im universum
die chance dass es irgendwo leben gibt
ist unheimlich groß unter passiert
sicher schlimme dinge und wir sind ok
wenn wir nicht wenn wir das nicht wissen
wir sind irgendwie okay damit das heißt
ich muss auch nicht auf unsere kleinen
erde alles wirklich wissen wo alles leid
entsteht
es ist wichtig dass wir irgendwo helfen
ich denke man muss helfen
aber man muss sich halt ziel setzen und
sagen empfehlungs los da helfe ich da
stecke ich und wenn es geht geld rein
und nicht eigene hilfe da stecke ich
geld ein und das sind profis die dort
helfen können gehen wir noch mal zurück
wirklich zur store und zu dieser effekt
kontrolle also man kann ja irgendwie
auch so was sagen die die zentrale idee
ist mit dem kontroll verlust
klarzukommen also zu anerkennen es gibt
die mir die kann ich nicht beeinflussen
ganz viel in ihrem buch geht genau darum
was ich kann eben nicht beeinflussen wie
groß wie schön wie klug ich bin auch
vielleicht nicht mehr reiche ich bin
aber ich kann beeinflussen ob ich
neidisch bin ob ich zufrieden bin oder
ob ich mir selbst genüge das ist so ein
ideal das die story sehr stark geprägt
hat die autarkie mit sich selbst
zufrieden zu sein
da würde ich sie gerne jetzt aber auch
noch einmal fragen ist das nicht
manchmal auch anmaßend anderen menschen
zu sagen guck mal du bist doch deines
eigenen glückes schmied es ist doch
einfach so dass die bedingungen die
staupe die und schreit
ungerecht sind die startbedingungen sind
schreiend ungerecht das ist tatsächlich
so
intelligenz nehmen wir beispielsweise
intelligenz intelligenz ist in unserer
gesellschaft sehr wichtig für den erfolg
für den materiellen ev den sie haben
wenn sie ein iq haben von 70 schaffen
sie es nicht wenn sie hingegen einen iq
haben intelligenzquotienten von 120 130
140 dann haben sie die möglichkeit gute
karriere zu machen viel geld zu
verdienen ein schönes leben sich zu
etablieren
die intelligenz ist ihnen geschehen
geschenk das mir geschenkt worden ist
ihm geschenkt worden ist jedes mal
geschenkt das ist genetisch determiniert
da kommen zwei stränge von genmaterial
von ihrer mutter und ihrem vater
zusammen die in ganz verschiedenen
möglichen kombinationen eine kombination
das sind sie und damit ist die
intelligenz also der intelligenzquotient
der terminiert die förderung kann den
doch auch nach vorne jetzt aber ich darf
noch schnell schnell schnell war im
mittelalter war intelligenz nicht so
wichtig als jäger und sammler war
intelligenz fast nicht wie ich da
mussten sie schnell rennen können sie
mussten schnell auf bäume klettern
können aber die intelligenz war weniger
wichtig wir haben jetzt per zufall eine
gesellschaft in der intelligenz wichtig
ist und das ist ein eine stadt bedingung
die wir nicht unter kontrolle haben sie
können da nicht viel machen
natürlich man kann ein wissen fördern
und jetzt kommt das zweite element rein
das sind ihre eltern sind sie in einen
haushalts geboren in ein elternhaus
gewohnt dass das gut ist oder sind sie
in ein elternhaus geboren oder schlecht
ist
ich habe meine eltern ich nicht
rekrutiert ich habe keinen
bewerbungsprozess durchgemacht von
meiner geburt und gesagt diese mutter
nämlich und diesen vater mache ich
nämlich und und ihr macht mich jetzt das
ist zufällig ich hatte glück
andere menschen haben pech an den
menschen haben noch möglich es sind wenn
sie es durch rechnen sind es so viele
faktoren in ihrem leben
die wichtig sind nicht mehr heutigen
gesellschaft wo sie aber keine kontrolle
darüber haben das müssen sie einfach
akzeptieren die startbedingungen sind
und sind wirklich schreiend ungerecht
und man kann natürlich ein bisschen
gesellschaftspolitisch etwas machen
übersteuern transferzahlungen
schulsysteme usw
das finde ich alles richtig
aber man darf die augen nicht
verschließen vor der tatsache dass diese
startbedingungen schreiend ungerecht
sind sie haben an einer stelle der im
interview glaube ich auch mal gesagt
dass sie sich mehr als früher jetzt für
soziale ungleichheit interessieren
würden gerade weil sie anerkennen dass
ein großteil dessen was sie für sich aus
lebensglück empfinden eigentlich vom
zufall abhängt ja und da würde mich
interessieren haben sie da schon
irgendwie eine vorläufige antwort
schreiben sie ein buch dazu da ist das
meer so ein hobby nein ich weiß noch
nicht wie sie mit dem umgehen aber aber
etwas hat es mir schon mal gezeigt das
hilft mir
ich zahle gern steuern ich zahle gern
steuern als wir nach berlin gezogen sind
von luzern nach bern haben alle zeit
nach bern ziehen die steuerhöhe der
schweiz wo man so viele steuern mit
sagen okay ich bezeuge ansteuern
und weil es mir so gut geht bezahle ich
gern steuern die aus transferleistungen
dann jene zugute kommen die mit den
falschen genen in die falschen familien
hineingeboren worden sind ich habe eben
das glück dass ich privilegiert bin und
dass das dass sich diese richtigen
startbedingungen hatte wissen sie
steuern müssen sie ja eh zahlen und ich
verstehe nicht leuchtet die sich
aufregen über die steuern lässt
der historiker zum da müssen sich sie
müssen steuern sie müssen lieben steuern
zu bezahlen
dann machen sie es einfach hat herr
albig ja auch so etwas gesagt wie es
gibt natürlich die effekt kontrolle die
uns absolut sinnvoll scheint ich sagen
dass das beispiel mit dem steuern
bezahlen es gibt vielleicht andere
momente sich wahnsinnig aufregend
darüber dass man die tram verpasst hat
bringt dann jetzt auch nicht sehr viel
oder sehr bedauern was man irgendwie
eine riesige nase hat bringt einem auch
nicht sehr viel aber es gibt andere
momente wo es fast ein bisschen
unheimlich ist oder vielleicht auch
wirklich unpassend wenn jemand nicht die
entsprechende negative emotion ausbildet
also nehmen wir beispielsweise haben sie
selber aus beispiel schon gebraucht eine
situation der eltern ein kind verlieren
da wäre es doch eigenartig wenn man
nicht eltern hätte die vielleicht ein
bisschen wie ob ihr schreiendes unglück
von sich geben würden um sich wirklich
beklagen und hadern mit dem schicksal
natürlich und dass wir das wird bei den
meisten menschen außer psychopathen
diese einem prozent psychopathen ist
ist das ist ein programm das das das
sichtungstraining ist das ist ein
menschliches programm das das
funktioniert dass das wird auch
passieren wenn ich ein kind verlieren
würde ich meine es fast unmöglich weiter
zu leben dann aber es kommt einmal den
moment wo sie sagen okay jetzt muss ich
wieder leben jetzt muss ich weiter
schauen uns muss ich nach vorne schauen
und das unglück dass dieses unglück
einfach akzeptieren um möglichst diese
traurigen emotionen abschließen und und
weiter nach vorne zu gehen
das geht nicht in zwei wochen der frau
sei nach einem tod aber man muss eine
sache trauerphase glaube ich auch nicht
auf fünf jahre zehn jahre 15 jahre
ausdehnen
das wäre das wäre eine sinnlose
ausdehnung nur um menschlich zu
erscheinen ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
ich hab das finde ich wahnsinnig
interessant herr der bälle was heißt
eigentlich menschlich zu sein weil sich
ihr buch gelesen habe habe ich wieder
gedacht so wäre ich auch gerne
irgendwie scheint alles so gut
aufzugehen für sie und ich habe für mich
jeden mann in meinem leben festgestellt
dass es einen satz gibt von markus
werner der schweizer schriftsteller der
an krebs gestorben ist den ich
unglaublich schätze der hat man gesagt
allein das zögern ist human dieses
moment des zögerns scheint mir ein
wesentlicher bestandteil des menschseins
zu sein
aber als ich gelesen habe aber ich
dachte naja vielleicht habe ich einfach
ein mickriges menschen geht
nein bei mir vielleicht stelle ich mich
so so dass aus so ruhig durchfließen
dass ich aus easy wegstecke dass ich
dass ich nicht mit mir habe
natürlich hatte ich mit mir ich habe mit
mir dass ich die heben ab und zu aus
friedlos raste meine man in negativen
wirklich toxischen emotionen nicht unter
kontrolle haben wie sie gerne unter
kontrolle hätte ich versuche besser zu
reden aber ich habe mit mir
es kommt es kommt teilweise
eine zehntelsekunde auf irgendjemanden
der halt irgendwas hat dass ich auch
gerne haben würde und dann versuche ich
mir wieder zu überlegen ein bist weißt
du was das ist zuhause
ich nehme dann diese tools daraus meine
toolbox und dann ist dieser neue wieder
verschwunden aber der erste moment so
die die erste zehntelsekunde
das kommt auch bei mir weil das ist fest
verdrahtet in unserem hirn diese
emotionen diesen fest verdrahtet die
haben ihren ursprung in unserer 300.000
jährigen geschichte als homo sapiens da
waren diese gefühle
diese diese effekte waren sinnvoll das
waren perfekte die uns zu dem gemacht
haben was wir sind die wahren fürs
überleben und für männchen weibchen
suchen aus positiv für unsere gene waren
die positiv ab heute in dieser
komplizierten welt sind sie oft nicht
mehr positiv zu werten
ich würde gerne noch über etwas anderes
mit ihnen sprechen interessant ist dass
sie nicht der einzige der sich jetzt
eben auf epic marc aurel seine kapazität
um diese historische philosophie wieder
versucht für unseren alltag neu zu
schreiben oder noch einmal neu zu
interpretieren sondern es kommen im
moment viele bücher auf den markt zum
thema historische philosophie es gibt
dazu auch eine geschichte auf unserer
kultur website die man nachlesen kann
und ich habe das auch den christoph
helbig gefragt warum es eigentlich im
moment so eine renaissance der store
gibt es gab mehrere ressourcen der stoa
auch in der neuzeit und die haben nicht
zufällig immer in extremen
krisensituation stattgefunden insofern
ist die heutige renaissance der steuer
eigentlich auch ein bisschen ein
krisensymptom also der erste große boom
stand fand während des dreißigjährigen
krieges statt
also wenn viele menschen sich heute
wieder den stolpern
zu wenden dann scheint es so zu sein
dass sie sich ein stück weit heimatlos
finden
gleichzeitig gibt es das versprechen
wenn du vernünftig deine situation
analysiert und vernünftig mit ihr umgeht
dann liegt dein glück eben doch an die
rund ist nicht irgendwelche anonymen
externen mächten anheim gestellt
also diese kombination von einer
gewissen heimatlosigkeit mit einem
vernunft optimismus und einem egalitären
individualismus also wir sind alle nur
menschen ja es gibt eben da nicht die
hierarchien zwischen leuten die
offenbarung empfangen und leuten die
keine empfangen oder welcher auch immer
das scheint mir ein gesamtpaket zu sein
was heute viele menschen erneut
anspricht stimmt das für sie auch also
ist durch die philosophie dass durch die
lustigsten krisensymptomen habe ich mich
noch nie überlegt für mich macht sie
einfach sehr viel sehen die historische
ich wieder so wie ich glaube man könnte
genauso argumentieren mit der der masse
von blümchen die rauskommen und sagen
wie mist auf die gefühle hören müsste
gefühle auspacken ist möglichst in euren
gefühlen schwelgen weil nur über
intuition kommt man weiter bauchgefühl
da stimmt also das gegenteil eigentlich
der store da gibt es auch da könnte man
auch sagen dass ein krisenphänomen ich
weiß nicht ob das eine interpretation
ist die die stimmt oder nicht stimmt ich
denke wenn man all diese
lebensphilosophie in anschaut
miteinander vergleicht ist ist die story
der stoizismus eine sehr tausende für
dieses komplizierte 21 jahrhundert sie
vermag sehr viel zu zu zu erreichen
und es gibt ja keinen der antike viele
schulen also die epicor er glaubt dass
gerade die könige und so weiter man kann
all diese geschichten nehmen dann kam
er später man habe noch andere schulen
und dann den achtzehnten jahrhundert kam
die romantik auf da gibt es auch gewisse
lebensphilosophie hinaus wenn man die
mal anschaut dann hat für mich einfach
des tourismus am meisten ist macht er
meistens in willich des komplizierten 21
jahrhundert ich denke wenn man es
einfach objektiv anstalt unsere heutige
welt jetzt unsere jahrzehnt ist sehr
stark
also ich würde das gegenteil von krise
sagen hier dass eine sehr stabile welt
verglichen mit allen anderen jahrzehnte
die es gegeben hat
sie können es vermutlich zurück 2500
jahre ich glaube nicht dass es ein
krisenphänomen ist ich glaube echt die
welt ist sehr kompliziert das leben ist
anstrengend geworden durch diese vielen
güte die wir haben durch diese durch die
starke arbeitsteilung sowie natürlich
alle profitieren jetzt überlagert von
einer digitalen welt die wir ja auch
noch meistern müssen
die müssen ja nicht nur ums leben
meistern das ist schon anstrengend genug
jetzt müssen noch eine digitale existenz
quasi uns generieren und uns uns und
schaffen das heißt leben ist anstrengend
es kompliziert geworden und da hilft
dieser ansatz gibt sicher noch andere
ansätze aber ich glaube die store hilft
tat
und vielleicht ist er auch unter anderem
genau das gemeint also der
kontrollverlust der dass ich eben
manifestieren könnte angesichts dieser
verschiedenen herausforderungen die
beschrieben haben
denen versucht man handhabbar zu machen
indem man mit stoischer gelassenheit
sozusagen darauf blickt oder ja aber ich
wünschte ich wüsste nicht was man sonst
tun sollte sollte man das glück im osten
suchen so hat man das glück im
immateriellen versuchen so wie man es
suchen im status den man erzählt draußen
das sind ja alles dinge die man nicht
unter kontrolle hat soll man den erfolg
suchen eben ich weiß nicht möglichst
viele kinder kriegen soll man den erfolg
suchen
ich wüsste nicht was es für andere
handhabbare werkzeuge geben oder ziele
gebe ich denke wenn man diese innere
festung baut und das ist ein wirklich
schöner stoische begriffen eine schöne
metapher diese innere festung bauen kann
dass man innerlich ruhig bleibt egal was
von draußen angeschossen wird mit
schlechten news und schlechten
ergebnissen dass man diese innere ruhe
behält
es gibt dieses schöne wort seelenruhe
der seelenfrieden in diese rinnen
festung
das ist von all diesen anderen
möglichkeiten anderen anderen
lebensphilosophien für mich die beste
die einleuchtendsten sie sagen auch dass
für sie eigentlich der prototypische
modernes durchbeißt wollen du fett
der 87-jährige us investmentbanker und
auch sein freund charly mangel
das hat mich doch einigermaßen
überrascht das müssen sie noch erklären
es ist halt so dass wissen sie wenn sie
an der börse sind und sponsoren der
börse ein investment in maxi kaufen oder
wieder verkaufe dann merken sie wie
wenig sie unter kontrolle haben und wie
stark man sich überschätzt man denkt
wenn man eine aktie kauft ja ich weiß
jetzt wie der hase läuft und dann auf
der anderen seite gibt er eine
gegenpartei die mitte genau gleichen mit
mit dem genau unterschiedlichen gründen
ihnen diese aktien verkauft als es gegen
geschäft tätig dh wenn sie in der
wirtschaft tätig sind besonders in den
finanzmärkten tätig sind wissen sie wie
wenig sie wissen das heißt ihr ego wird
automatisch klein gestaucht
wir wissen wie man realisiert dann man
weiß extrem wenig wissen nicht so gut
wie wir denken wir wissen und das
handeln an den börsen beispielsweise ist
eine gute übung und wenn sie diese
beiden leute wollen betont und charly
manga anschauen
das sind eigentlich modernen historiker
ob die jetzt milliarden geld gewinnen
oder verlieren das den 14
die sind innerlich so ruhig weil sie hat
schon lange in diesen finanzaktien und
weil sie eben auf die story gelesen
haben wir sehen innerlich so gut dass es
die gar nicht betrifft also dort habe
ich so eine dritte quelle gefunden
inspiration ist bei diesen
value-investoren dass sie nicht die
traders die jeden tag schreiben sondern
wirklich langfristig investieren da gibt
es das ist eine gute übung an den
finanzmärkten tätig zu sein
das ist alles so rational also mann mann
soll irgendwie gut berechnen können mit
den effekten umgehen
braucht es da auch noch den moment
vielleicht doch das mit waltz
der erste effekt ist immer da die erste
institution dieses gefühl des mitleids
dieses gefühl des des wohls des zorns
das kommt aus dass ein psychopath kommt
immer das ist immer automatisch dabei
eine sekunde lang sie können mit siegen
von mir aus fünf sekunden lang lassen
aber dann bitte schalten sie das hirn
ein und untersuchen sie diese diese
effekte ein bisschen unter kontrolle zu
halten das ist ist durch antwort hirn
einschalten ruhe genießen ich danke
ihnen sehr herr der bälle börse gegangen
nächste woche geht yves bost dem
erfolgsgeheimnis von tv serien auf den
grund warum sind wir süchtig nach
breaking bad martin oder der bestatter
ich hoffe sie sind süchtig nach
sternstunden in diesem sinn bis bald und
eine gute woche
[Musik]